alors nous voici maintenant dans un
nouvel endroit à savoir le hall d'entrée
du théâtre qui absolument magnifique et
on va parler de choses concrètes
j'encourage les personnes à se procurer
le petit livre
bleu tout est dedans vous êtes d'accord
on est d'accord et alors dites-moi
comment ça marche alors alors le site
www.theatrmontancier.com
ouvert 24h/ 24 pour faire ses
réservations à n'importe quelle heure du
jour et de la nuit le téléphone à des
heures précises 01 39 20 1600 quand on
ne répond pas il a un répondeur et en
direct au guichet également à des heures
précises on peut être conseillé par
Sabrina qui peut répondre à des
questions on peut aussi répondre par
mail à des questions des spectateurs a
déjà reçu quelques réponses des
questions et des réponses absolument on
aime bien dialoger avec les
spectateursim très intéressant oui
j'imagine là vous avez déjà des retours
là en ce début de saison on a très
heureux retours on
a des retours spontanés de spectateurs
qui nous ont envoyé des mails carrément
donc on les remercie et c'était à quel
propos vous parliez du votre l'attention
particulière que vous vouliez donné à
l'accueil alors ils nous ont parlé de
l'accueil voilà ils ont remarqué même
que les ouvreuses étaient dotées d'un
foulard bleu ils nous ont parlé de du
spectacle de l'originalité de Philippe
gentil et de la pluridisciplinarité de
la programmation parce qu'il faut quand
même avouer que il y en a pour tous les
goûts tout à fait et il y en a aussi
pour toutes les bourses justement parce
que quelquefois pour les personnes
le théâtre égal cher mais en fait pas
forcément alors la
politique pass ouis et en plus 45
minutes avant chaque spectacle nous
ouvrons des places à 5 € d'accord alors
donc là comment on fait on vient on fait
que et on achète des places à 5 € et on
est placé très bien mais avec pas
tellement de place pour les jambes pas
de confort mais enfin un peu moins de
confort que sur les autres places mais
on voit tous les spectacles à 5 € c'est
génial ça voilà et puis ensuite avec la
carte d'adhésion les tarifs sont bas il
y a des tarifs pour les moins de 26 ans
en fait ouais donc c'est voilà bien
étendu la carte de famille nombreuse à
la carte vermeille donc en réalité il y
a quand même beaucoup de possibilité
d'avoir le tarif rédit d'accord ben il
faut mieux aller 10 fois par an au
théâtre en payant peu cher qu'une seule
fois en payant très cher bon d'accord
c'est notre crédau c'est l'ordonnance du
médecin
vous vous avez raison de parler de ça il
s'agit de ça effectivement santé le
théâtre est vital pour l'
pr on peut pas passer sa vie dans la
télévision qui délivre une certaine
vision du monde mais c'est important
d'interroger cette vision du monde et
c'est en allant au théâtre que on peut
interroger cette vision du monde qui est
fabriquée par certains médias et il y a
autre chose il y a aussi de la poésie il
y a aussi de du rêve et le théâtre est
là pour dispenser cela c'est très
important je pense que chez l'homme il y
a cette aspiration à à cela et que le
théâtre peut y répondre d'accord depuis
toujours sauf que depuis toujours on est
on est un peu moins dans le concret que
vous é tout à l'heure ououi mais non
mais c'est bien j'avais deux trois
petites questions sûrement idiote euh il
y a plus de souffleur non ça n'existe
plus maintenant les comédiens
connaissent leur texte ah d'accord c'est
bête j'aurais bien aimé faire souffleuse
et bon plus de souffle et plus de trois
coups non plus c'est ce que j'allais
demander voilà alors plus de trois coups
non plus pourquoi je sais pas qu ça
coûte ah ben c'est
pas dire c'est une évolution esthétique
vous savez le théâtre soi-disant pour se
moderniser enever les trois coups en
particulier c'est passé à la trape je
dire ouais ouais c'estôle mais euh j'ai
pas envie de les remettre ben on nexclut
pas de les remettre faire bien les faire
non onclut pas de les remettre bien sûr
on en parlera avec les m en scène il y a
a il y a des œuvres qui s'y prêteront et
d'autres moins parce qu'en fait les
trois coups c'était au début du
spectacle oui pour comm on les
réentendit après non
non non juste au début bon al c'est rien
du tout bon ben alors ce que je vous
propose c'est d'en parler à Michel Fau
hein l'histoire des trois coups ah ben
ça il sera pas il sera pas à convaincre
Michel Fau sur les trois coups l'IM ah
ou moi aussi génial et bien on va
pouvoir en parler avec quelqu'un que ça
concerne à savoir le metteur en scène
Michel fa qui propose qui répète pardon
en ce moment son spectacle demain il
fera jour de monterl ensuite il va aussi
nous parler d'un futur spectacle d'une
future création pour celle-ci
versaillaise à savoir le Misanthrope ou
la trabilaire amoureux du célibrtime
Molière alors chute sans bruit on y
va
Michel fa bonjour merci de nous accorder
un peu de temps avant une répétition
dites-moi un peu quelle est cette pièce
c'est une pièce d'enine monterland qui
s'appelle demain il fera jour ouis et
qui date de 1949 d'accord est-ce qu'elle
est connue cette pièce j'ai pas c'est
une pièce qui est pas connue non je
pense qu'elle avait jamais été remontée
depuis création c'est une pièce qui
avait à l'époque av beaucoup heuré les
gens et beaucoup choqué parce que ça
parle de la Seconde Guerre mondiale ça
se passe en 1945 et et parler de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale en 49 c'était un
sujet très très très brûlant en fait
ouais d'accord et en plus il monland
donne un regard pas du tout maniquéen
sur sur cette période il il observe un
couple de de
bourgeois euh dans le l'homme a été plus
ou moins
euh pas Cabo mais il a euh il a défendu
un allemand pendant la guerre et cetera
ouais ça pe coûé cher et euh donc il il
montre le cette période terrible mais
euh euh vu avec un angle particulier
qu'on a pas l'habitude de voir quoi
enfin avec avec des gens qui qui étaient
ni des résistants ni des collabos mais
qui étaient un petit peu un peu
neutre pas neutre mais un peu
inconscient et un peu
euh qui comprenait qui concevait pas
trop ce qui se passe en fait à cette
époque il y avait toute une population
ou ou toute une population et qui était
assez préservée en fait parce qu'ils
étaient pas juifs ils étaient pas
communistes ils étaient pas homosexuel
il av aucune raison d'être inquiété
d'accord et dites-moi alors vous vous
jouez qui moi je joue le père le père
qui qui n'a pas une attitude très claire
pendant la guerre en fait d'accord et
vous mettez en scène voilà c'est lad
druer qui joue le rôle de la mère qui
est une femme apparemment assez assez
futile assez inconsciente et puis qui va
se révéler
après un être humain comme tous les
autres et puis on a un fils qui est joué
par LC mobillan et
qui en fait qui qui nous annonce qui qui
veut entrer dans la Résistance donc au
début les parce que la guerre est pas
finie la guerre non c'est en 45 ah oui
d'accord donc au début le père veut pas
la mère elle veut parce qu'elle elle
gâte son enfant et et puis après ça ça
s'inverse c'estàd la mère a peur donc
elle veut plus qui qu'il entre en
résistance et le père lui espère se
racheter une ça l'arrange quelque part
voilà une honnêteté d'accord si son fils
entre dans la Résistance c'est terrible
parce que laver finalement l'honneur de
la famille réunie quoi chose il y a
quelque chose de sacrificiel làdedans
c'est c'est ce qui est beau c'est que la
pièce elle commence comme comme un drame
bourgeois et à la fin elle finit comme
une tragédie parce que oui parce que
vous faites souvent le rapprochement
entre monterland et et les Grecs mais
c'était lui aussi qui en parlait
beaucoup surtout les Romains en fait il
était passionné par l'Empire romain
d'accord et vous allez revenir pour le
Misanthrope ou la trabilaire amoureux
voilà et là vous allez faire quoi cette
fois-ci bah les deux je joue et je mets
en scène toujours pareil comme ça je
joue des beaux rôles des beaux textes
avec des gens bien en fait oui vous
choisissez tout ce que vous c'est très
important moi j'arrive pas à jouer tout
seul donc j'ai besoin de de partenaire
et et c'est très important pour moi le
donc je ne peux travailler qu'avec des
gens avec qui j'ai une complicité très
forte et surtout des gens qui me font
qui me font rêver le misantthrope sera
voilà c'est une création du Théâtre
montancier le 21 janvier et c'est joué à
partir du 21 voilà on joue 5 fois et
après on reprend le 30 janvier au T de
l'œuvre à Paris d'accord et là on aura
Julie de pardieu ah oui oui il il a que
des créatures formidables Julie de
pardieu outre votre personne voilà
edit Scob Jean-Pierre laoris Jean-Paul
Muel Laur Lucile Simon Frédéric giroutru
Frédric le sacripand qui s'appelle
maintenant frédri le
sarpan Roland Menou et Fabrice cal voilà
d'accord et alors qu'est-ce que quel est
la motivation de de re enfin de de
mettre en scène une pièce qui était déjà
jouée rejoué et mise et remise en scène
plus moi j'aime bien trouver des voilà
j'aime bien monter des pièces qui qui
sont pas trop connues qui n'ont pas été
monté depuis longtemps et Cera là c'est
pas le cas
le et en même
temps en lisant cette pièce parce que
moi je suis passionné par le répertoire
je me suis dit qu'elle avait qu'avec le
temps elle avait été un peu déformée et
on aimerait revenir à l'origine vraiment
de la pièce en lisant beaucoup de de
document sur la création on à l'époque
c'était vraiment une pièce très très
drôle et très très méchante en fait il y
avait la férocité et le burlesque qui
était mélangé et on a un peu perdu ça
avec le temps et on avait peut-être
besoin de passer par là avec les
différentes visions des mette en scène
successif vouz dire oui des acteurs qui
l'ont joué on est allé vers quelque
chose souvent de d'un peu austère ou
d'un peu sentimental ou d'un peu sérieux
et et c'est pour ça que j'ai eu envie de
remonter cette pièce pour pour redonner
sa couleur orig fois insolente
terrifiante et puis et puis drôle très
très drôle en fait d'accord revenir à
l'essence même de de ce qu'avait voulu
ce qu' a voulu créer Molère ouais parce
qu' il y a des écrits quand même et
Molière jouit le rôle comme il jouait
laavare comme il jouit le mal imaginaire
c'est pour ça qu'il avait un costume
vert comme ganarel et qui était la
couleur de la folie et c'est pour ça
qu'elle cesse on l'appelle l'homme au
ruban vert et jouit ça vraiment à
trabilaire c'est-à-dire qu'il jouit ça
comme comme un malade à trabilire ça
veut dire quoi ve dire qu'il fait de la
bille ça veut dire qu'il oui une trop
forte s voilà c'est ça c'est parce qu'il
il a la rage il a la il a la
haine donc ça joue sur son comportement
sur son caractère et il jouit ça de
façon très enfin d'après le le peu
d'écrit qu'on a il jouit ça de façon
très organique et on voudrait revenir à
ça et pareil le personnage de Siman on
va on voudrait travailler sur le côté
mondain et vénéneux du personnage qu'on
a beaucoup gommé ces dernières années et
ce qui est beau avec Julie de Pardus
c'est qu'elle a pas du tout peur de ça
et de jouer là-dessus et du coup c'est
beaucoup plus drôle et beaucoup plus
méchant que ce qu'on voit d'habitude je
pense d'accord
ok alors nous sommes ici dans le foyer
du théâtre montancier encore un lieu
magnifique à découvrir et alors à quoi
ça sert cet endroit exactement quelle
est sa fonction alors ça sert à
accueillir les spectateurs avant et
pendant les entrates avant parce qu'ils
arrivent en avance on essaie qu'ils
arrivent un peu en avance parce qu'on
organise une restauration légère à
l'intention des spectateurs d'accord
donc si on peut prendre un verre une
coupe de champagne un coca nor quoi et
puis nous allons essayer donc de réunir
le public et les artistes à l'issue des
spectacles pour des rencontres des
signatures des débat d'accord donc c'est
là que ça va se passer ça se passera ici
donc par exemple Bernard Pivot je sais
qu' il est prévu ser là il viendra
signer ses livres ici voilà Michel Fau
comme on a dit voilà Thomas
Fersen signer ses disque on va pouvoir
le toucher et Alex bin ça va être super
et Alex Baupin B c'est génial li de
rassemblement déjà pour le public car le
public quand il ser au théâtre il aime
bien parler oui quand il repè un copain
au 3è rang bah là on fait le point
onrouve parler entre soi avant ou après
et également un lieu d'échange jeun VI
avec les artistes ouais bon ben écoutez
on a hâte d'y être tout à fait ai voilà
ben merci merci à très bientôt à très
bientôt qu'on parle de nouvelles choses
tout à fait au revoir
merci